stell dir vor ein neurowissenschaftler
schleicht sich eines nachts heimlich in
sein schlafzimmer
er betreibt ich und schleppt ich in sein
labor dort operiert er sorgfältig das
gehirn aus seinem schädel und legt es in
erlösung
dann schliesst er es an eine riesige
maschine an wo man sie verarbeitet die
nervenimpulse deines gehirns und
versorgt es mit unzähligen signal durch
elektrische impulse kann der
wissenschaftler jeden nur denkbaren
wahrnehmungs eindruck in die erzeugen
und ihr eine täuschend echte welt
vorgaukeln
unser bewusstes erleben wird nämlich
durch vorgänge im gehirn erzeugt den
körper braucht es dazu nicht
wenn du etwa eine blume siehst dann
leitet ein auge die information direkt
an dein gehirn weiter und dieses erzeugt
dann den eindruck einer blume den weg
von der blume übers auge zum gehirn
könnte man sich sparen wenn man den
identischen gehirn zustand künstlich
erzeugen könnte dasselbe gilt für musik
der schmerzen
oder sogar für die liebe durch ge
hirnstimulation kann man die er
prinzipiell alles mögliche vorgaukeln
woher weißt du also dass das nicht
bereits geschieht und zwar mit dir jetzt
vielleicht schwingt dein gehirn zur zeit
gerade nährlösung und wird durch tätige
ziel stimuliert so dass du nur glaubst
ein philosoph iks video zu schauen
unmöglich woher nimmst du die gewissheit
rené descartes behauptete im siebzehnten
jahrhundert man könne eine absolute
gewissheit erlangen
es gebe etwas das niemand bezweifeln
kann und zwar die tatsache dass ich
jetzt gerade denke dann aber muss es
mich auch geben keine gedanken ohne
denker cogito ergo sum ich denke also
bin ich aber woher weiß ich dass ich
nicht nur denken sondern dass die welt
wirklich so ist wie ich sie erlebe
woher wissen wir dass es die welt
wirklich gibt und kannst du ausschließen
dass du bloß ein gehirn im tank bist